si è fatto male a tutti in salita vitale
e oggi vedremo un nuovo trend che sta
spopolando su instagram
ho visto privi di sinistra meno di
questo trend in cui delle persone delle
ragazze asiatiche mangiano del ghiaccio
ma del ghiaccio con del succo dentro le
pazzesca questa cosa sono rimasta
incantata da questi video che da un lato
mi fa uno strano dall'altro sono
bellissimi da vedere quindi solo quello
di vedere voi voi cosa ne pensate
è che effetto fa a voi e sono curiosa
volti di vederne altri e di capire come
fanno i più trovato anche dei file
quindi voglio vedere che cosa fanno su
bell anche se volete vedere le reazioni
a trend assurdi prendete i pop corn e
video tutto schermo e iniziamo subito
allora mangiano le galline di ghiaccio
toccando le palline per questo che su
queste
per settore non la di ghiaccio come
faccio a mangiarlo ai denti fino a
quest'anno facendo male i denti ecco
questi questo lo portassi si guarda allo
strutto dentro una stranissima stato già
farle reds sembrano molto sul conto e
quale no questa è la nostra più congela
per me questa si sta sciogliendo vedi
qui hanno un'espressione molto non è un
trans con queste possono tutto normale
mangiare dei venti di viaggio fa niente
colorno una barretta il ghiaccio
la macchina non va detta chiediamo che
bello dentro ma stranissima questa cosa
mi fa un po senso perché sembra un vetro
ho imparato assegnazioni va beh questo è
giusto difendere alquanto sono se il
ghiaccio è molto duro mi attaccano i
denti questo un po meglio come succede
che mangia un pezzo degli di assolo mese
già dal cervello del freddo
che carino su un pezzo di questo
aspettando solo a mangiare una tastiera
[Applauso]
chiusa perché sono è bello da sentire ma
non fa male
insomma l'idea che cosa stranissima
piena mi raccomando adesso non ha dato a
congelare le tastiere lontana la stessa
si scoprì che realtà è una tastiera
terra stata inizialmente mangiando le
tastiere non so questi sono bellissimi
con liquido vento sembra veramente una
bottiglia di vetro di però avevamo gli
occhi adesso per strano miei cari
ma il ghiaccio dove ancora si mostrano
questa cosa voi riuscireste mai mangiare
il piatto così oddio fanno bene fa
impressione però sembra che secondo ad
un punto lo dica un'altra pastiera carlo
ma non solo se fosse una cosa del tutto
normale che bayern sto mangiando la
tastiera di ghiaccio dove stiamo facendo
un video anche perché topolino tra
l'altro visto che c'è un tutorial su
come farlo e magari poi lo guardiamo i
difetti se stasera il se volete che lo
proviamo anche noi se volete che
perdiamo tutti i denti
io non l'ho gas per questa cosa strana
maschera
ecco qua da questo male con fighissimi
per quanto il liquido dentro
ecco questi sono i minimalisti con
questi sono quelli di fortuny sta però
nessuno la nostra incantata ma non
liquido dentro
così sembra un aborto ghiaccio
se nessuno è bello e molto questo mr
il suono quello che fa prossima
per me non sarà mai ma rischiano fino a
probabilmente si sarà sbrodolato addosso
ma siamo tutti sono da un viaggio a roma
[Musica]
ma per quella mezza così quale lascia
annuncia quindi non forse è nato così
tipo una bevanda da bere con la
cannuccia per poi dopo è però non l'ha
ma anzi e allora non contatterà proviamo
a mangiarla non lo so io cosa enorme
c'è qualcosa di rosa dentro le
[Musica]
televisioni entriamo messo il microfono
capire se le cuffie che si sente
benissimo ma cominciando un'altra
maschera una maschera terapici un pò
inquietante questo che mangiano la
maschera con gli occhi il naso la bocca
[Musica]
amore dentro sente quel pane comito il
fiore dentro amici
credi che non buttano via libero
noi che cade bensì come stanno i vostri
denti che sembra normale mi sento dolore
[Musica]
la paladina sembra tumori nel pensi
[Applauso]
per bello da vedere non so queste
bellissime con tantissimi questo chiasso
spesso ti rinfresca un polpaccio
basta quando non per tutto e si sente ma
con le fragole due enormi bello che
rimangono prima dell'amministrazione
mi sono aspettavamo così
ma vediamo queste stampini anno penso
fosse uno stampino invece col ghiaccio a
forma di spongebob
e questo quanto si sente si è fatto male
o si è fatta male ardente ha fuso
iniziata la prima volta che lo provava
[Musica]
penso composto il contenitore con questo
silvia se tutto ghiaccio simest
rarissima sta cosa
questi sono i file con un atto così lo
sanno
la vera si pescava oddio abbiamo anche
casinò poi per terrazze a lo mangiano
comunque non lo spreca un po strano
ma vi regalo
sembra che non vedono l'ora di mangiarne
proprio io ho fiducia in tutti gli altri
insaccati roma proprio come se mi piace
tanto che come qualsiasi cosa succeda in
questi face continuano comunque a
mangiarlo sei pronto dall'altro lato so
anch'io ho un becchino le ama
pietro maso mi è venuta a 6 che ha detto
questo anche se la butta in faccia chi
lo mangia dunque facciamo anche noi
insomma anche noi lo cancelliamo ha
bisogno di battere in testa comunque
queste cose sono troppo leader
per un omaggio allo stesso ma quello che
faranno le facce che vada bene con da
romanzo anche a trattare da via via via
con quel coltello perché aveva paura
oddio ma sembra che vieta una parola in
italiano
questo è quello che prima si no niente
non si rompe questo importante mangiarlo
migliora importante lui ha paura
ma dove vanno questi video dentro una
volta dal bagno ai c'è una bacinella
fatto tranquillamente sarà pure
pericoloso perché il ghiaccio così
l'acqua
ok ma lui ha sempre più fame restivo il
cervello e racconterà attenta
adesso ancora non l'ho mai interrogato
come ho fatto a bronte stramaglia che
dice lo proviamo anche noi ma
soprattutto se la bambina al dietro
sconvolta di bomba
ma cosa fare le norme vanno mai
mangiandosi le fragole pesche roma solo
canale importante mangiare
chissenefrega dall'angolo a casa lo vedi
che sembrano all'importante al mondiale
[Risate]
stava cantando
[Musica]
e allora spiega secondo voi se lo sapete
questa mattina valere sono due o perché
hanno tutti la moglie toni anche tra
l'altro continuano a mangiare qualsiasi
cosa succeda continuano a guardare anche
a tripoli è un altro bambino sconvolto
che ci aiuta un coltello nano si grande
in mano a tutti e paura allora disk e si
vuole un cucchiaio una ciotola colorante
quindi usando un colorante alimentare
dice se vuoi avere quella forma tonda
usa una ciotola tondar lo zucchero
immagino così il succo dentro è più
buono vi fate di dissolvere lo zucchero
quindi abbiamo anche dal tutorial se
vogliamo trovarlo facciamo seguito video
16 ai lo proviamo anche noi questa è
stata colpita
anche d'inverno troppo freddo di che
colore rifacciamo verdi il bel giusto se
non l'ha voluto fare viola stava solo di
vari colori
quindi lo metto in freezer ovviamente
però quanto tempo deve stare ok dice di
lasciarlo un'ora in freezer ma posso
vedere mentre lavava i piatti quindi il
ghiaccio sensoli di vita sono l'esterno
vediamo non si è solidificato un po più
del molo c erano i video trend fateci
sapere cosa ne pensate nei commenti se
secondo voi è una cavolata se vi piace
guardarli se vita senso se vi piace se
vorreste provarlo anche voi se volete
che lo proviamo anche noi ce n'è stato
un bel laica in questo video e proveremo
a farlo anche noi sa chissà come andrà
lo facciamo noi gli facciamo verdi si
constati lui allora fino a 14 castellini
su cui cliccare per vedere i nostri
altri video le nostre generazioni ai
nostri challenge video divertenti
cliccate su quella che preferite ma
quando di sicurezza